let's head over to mojo with 95.5 the
bull to introduce our very first act
hey guys let's start our special evening
performances with russell dickerson
one of the hottest new performers in
country music here he is with joy to the
world
hey vegas it's russell dickerson here
and i know it's been an absolutely crazy
year
but uh and we haven't been able to get
out there and see you guys like we
always do
but nothing brings us together like some
good old christmas music
so i'm gonna play you a little christmas
jam but first i got to say thank you so
much
to 95.5 the bull and opportunity village
such an amazing organization so thank
you all for
your donations and uh here's a little
christmas song for you
joy to the world
the lord is gone
let earth receive
her king
and let every heart
prepare him
[Music]
and
[Music]
um
with truth and grace
and makes the nations prove
[Music]
the glories are
his righteousness
and wonders of his love
and wonders
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you may recognize our next act as a
winner of america's got talent who's
gone on to create a successful residency
at the link
yeah joining us now with a little
holiday magic is matt franco
ho ho ho merry christmas happy holidays
if you haven't noticed i am not santa
i'm matt franco
and thanks for being with me on this
very sunny christmas
it's one of my favorite holidays and
since i was a little kid
the only thing i asked santa for was a
deck of cards
every year a deck of cards and you know
what i'm glad i did because
it eventually took me to here in las
vegas
in fact till this day it's all i ask for
my wife says matt what do you want for
christmas i say
how about another deck of cards and you
know what for good reason
i can show you some really cool stuff
like this
when you snap like that you actually get
four aces to appear almost as if by
magic we can use any cards but aces will
be just fine
hearts diamonds spades and clubs
watch now we'll start very simple all i
do is i leave one ace on the table
three in the hand i'll show you how to
make one ace travel
we use a secret tekken technique in
magic called palming
all i do is i palm the card like this
you don't see it from this side
or this side because it's invisible but
it is there you take it all you do is
you set it down next to the other ace
i know it seems impossible stay with me
we have the red ones here
and that leaves on the table the two
black aces
which will stay on the table so we now
have hearts and diamonds
hearts is next watch closely i palm the
ace like this
and all you do is you set it down right
there on the table
that leaves just one left please settle
down it's just a card trick
the ace of diamonds is the most amazing
this time you can see
three aces here on the table
and this looks about like the right spot
all you do is you set it down give it a
rub
nothing happened yet okay nothing
happened yet because i forgot to do the
riffle it's not until i
do that that it turns invisible you
can't see it there but it's there
without even touching you wave like this
and that's one
two three four aces what please
settle down relax i can see you clapping
at home oh my god standing ovation thank
you
oh my god over in summerlin and
henderson too thank you very much i
appreciate it
but let me tell you with these four aces
you have to be kind of careful
because if you deal them in the face
down position you can see them but the
crazy thing
is when you try to do it face up for
example because they start to disappear
in real time they're actually just gone
completely
my friends thank you so much for
watching my silly little
situation my silly little demonstration
i don't know if it's a situation i don't
know what it is
all i know is i'm excited for the
holidays and they're here just around
the corner
and i'm sorry you had to see that matt
franco out thanks for watching
that's great magic from matt franco up
next a group with an impressive
eight acm awards nine cma awards and
four grammys
here's little big town with children go
where i cindy
baby boy
[Music]
one was a
[Music]
[Music]
three cause the three was in hebrew
children
two was appalling silas one was a little
bitty baby
bart bone born in bethlehem
children go where
the four was the four that stood at the
door three was the hebrew children
two was appalling silas
born in bethlehem
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
was the ten commandments nine was a nine
that stood out in the line
eight was the eighth that waited at the
gate seven was the seventh and never got
to heaven
six was a six it didn't get faced
[Applause]
born in bethlehem
[Applause]
children boys
[Music]
hey
[Music]
shine
[Music]
shall see
please praise jesus
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
tonight
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
the incredible performers joining us for
this show are also raising money for a
very special cause
opportunity village yeah alex
opportunity village as i'm sure you
know is dedicated to helping adults with
disabilities in all kinds of ways from
finding jobs
housing even building lifelong
friendships over the years opportunity
village has become a valuable part of
our community
we are grateful for the opportunity to
help them during this very challenging
time
well if you're still looking for gift
ideas right now check this out langler
this is pretty nice yeah i can check it
out because i'm wearing it you can see
here
uh it's the vegas golden knights it's
their new third jerseys
uh coming up throughout the show we're
gonna see and hear greetings from some
of the vegas golden knights who proudly
support opportunity village
the vegas golden knights gold and retro
jerseys
are available at the arsenal at city
national arena
or online at vegasteamstore.com
here's one of the biggest golden nights
now for my family yours have a safe and
happy holidays
support our friends at opportunity
village by going to ov gift.com
a very sunny christmas on 8 news now is
sponsored by subaru of las vegas
8 news now in sunny 106.5 present a very
sunny christmas
a special benefit for opportunity
village in this unprecedented year
without the magical forest
las vegas headliners and performers are
coming together to raise money for
opportunity village and get us into the
holiday spirit
join us friday december 18th at 3 p.m
for a very sunny christmas on 8 news now
a very sunny christmas on 8 news now
is sponsored by subaru of las vegas
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to a very sunny christmas
benefiting opportunity village
the next few minutes are all about
recreating the magic of an era
and one of the best to do it the bronx
wanderers
they're joining us with their rendition
of jingle bells and stick around because
after their performance
we'll be treated to performance from
country superstar
darius rucker sit back relax and enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
know what fun it is
[Music]
[Music]
what fun it is
[Music]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
oh
what fun it is
[Music]
[Music]
happy holidays
[Music]
tiny little boots covered in snow
[Music]
watching all the presents patiently
milk and cookies on a plate santa claus
is on his way the kids should be
fast asleep
these littles are ringing
in their head
twisting like little tops in
there because
i am asleep but it's no
[Music]
the use being
out the window to see what they can
see is a candy cane christmas
sweet as it can't
[Music]
be
[Music]
they've said i made it so they
can say look what he
brought
[Applause]
[Music]
but it's no
[Music]
it's a candy cane christmas
sweet as it can
be
it's a candy cane christmas
sweet as it
can be
[Music]
our next performer is a force in las
vegas entertainment consulting on more
than a dozen headline shows he's worked
with boys to men
and wayne newton just to name a few but
now he's joining us with his own bit of
holiday magic
here's douglas lefty leverage
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
hey knights fans i'm max fashreddy and i
want to wish everyone a merry christmas
and a happy holidays from my family to
yours
if you're able to support our friends at
opportunity village please go to
dot com
[Music]
[Applause]
a very sunny christmas on eight news now
is sponsored by subaru of las vegas
eight news now and sunny 106.5 present a
very sunny christmas
a special benefit for opportunity
village in this unprecedented year
without the magical forest
las vegas headliners and performers are
coming together to raise money for
opportunity village and get us into the
holiday spirit
join us friday december 18th at 3 p.m
for a very sunny christmas on 8 news now
a very sunny christmas on 8 news now
is sponsored by subaru of las vegas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to a very sunny christmas
up next we're bringing you a magician
whose performances have garnered over
one
billion views he's a regular on pawn
stars currently headlining at the
tropicana resort and casino
here's murray the magician and his
fiancee showgirl danny elizabeth
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
from one great magician to another jen
cramer was named female magician of the
year by the international magicians
society
and she'll join us here in just a few
minutes she will reappear she'll be
joined by xavier mortimer another
enchanting magician who's a best of las
vegas award winner
during the pandemic he's performed on
social media to more than 7 million
viewers
but first here's jen cramer hi everyone
i'm jen cramer
a magician here in las vegas wishing you
a magical holiday season check this out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it really is a magical time of the year
here's wishing you lots of magic this
holiday season
happy holidays everybody
hi this is xavier moore happy holidays
to everyone
today i'm going to show you how to make
your own candy canes
for that you need to cut a little bit of
wrapping paper
just like this
and you are going to roll the paper not
too tight
but so it looks like a little tube
just like this now you need some sugar
uh cane sugar any type of sugar is gonna
be fine
you put it just inside the roll
as long as it doesn't
go in the back so you close a roll
and you roll like this
make the shape of the candy it's gonna
harden
and now you get yourself
a real candy cane
merry christmas we'd like to thank all
of the tremendous acts we've seen over
the past half hour for joining us for
this special
benefiting opportunity village from all
of us here at 8 news now and for the
good people at sunny 106.5
happy holidays
[Music]
countdown to 2021 new year's eve
starting at 9 pm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to a half hour of magic songs
and games right here
on 8 news now together with us at sunny
106.5
this is a very sunny christmas
benefiting opportunity village
i'm aj and i'm joanna right now we've
got a special performance for you from
someone who first
burst onto the music scene at 16. her
career took off from there and joining
us now with god rest
you marry gentlemen here's debbie gibson
god rest you marry gentlemen
let nothing you dismay
remember christ our savior was born on
christmas day
to save us all from satan's power when
we
have gone australia
tithings of comfort and joy
comfort enjoy your
[Music]
is
[Music]
his mother mary did nothing
take
of comfort and joy comfort
and joy oh tidings of comfort and joy
[Music]
to free all those who trusted him from
[Music]
satan's
[Music]
[Music]
nothing you deserve remember
christ our savior was born on christmas
day
to save us all from satan's
and
happy holidays everyone
all right our next group they are always
competitive with anyone who takes the
court against them
yes we are joining now with a little
competitive fun between teammates
it's the las vegas aces we are here
right now
inside mandalay bay resort joined by las
vegas ace's very own we've got
asia wilson and kelsey plum
it's going to be a very intense battle
of something that we're calling
who will ace holiday trivia all right
mojo you feel the intensity here i feel
the intensity you can cut it with a
knife let's just jump right into this
here before things get weird here we go
first question how many americans buy
artificial christmas trees each year is
it
70 80 or 90 percent
[Applause]
me asia um i must say 70.
70 is not correct 90. not currently
got that right 88
i said it judges what do we do is that a
tie
for that one
all right kelsey's on the board all
right let's do it next question
all right what is the highest grossing
christmas movie
of all time is it the polar express
home alone or elf home alone
the answer is home alone crazy okay
next question what is the most recorded
christmas song
of all time oh no multiple choice go for
it asia
[Laughter]
i just pressed it so i get the answer
first okay is it
white christmas silent night or oh
christmas tree
you can't press the button already press
it okay we'll go
um silent night she got ready
and we have reached our first
controversy here all right here we go
next question
in the song frosty the snowman what made
frosty come to life
was it the nose
cara knows not correct no
was it an old silk hat coal for his eyes
or a scarf around his neck
asia scarf around his neck
next question the tv special how the
grinch stole christmas
what three words best describe the
grinch
is it sad stinky scary i've been called
that
uh stink stank stunk or silly sloppy
slender
[Music]
hey hey wow whatever
whatever bee drinky slanky smoky
whatever you say yes you're wasting time
you're wasting time saying wrong answers
i got the right ones over here everybody
stretch out final question here
all right the ten this is intense how
many reindeer
listen to the question we're in the
story towards the night before
christmas is it seven eight or nine
nine not correct
seven or eight you gotta pick one or the
other
commit it's seven
no eight maybe is
eight and we know why um because rudolph
didn't make it
correct oh that's a point that is a
point
in that story anyway no point that's a
bonus
i get two points for that and guess what
you're still losing i get two points for
that because
you didn't even know why you were just
naming it uh no idea see our own judges
what who we got here i know it's very
close but
it looks like kelsey is our kelsey
that's crazy i guess you could say you
aced holiday
trivia
up next performances from a prolific
trumpeter
followed by a comedian with a special
announcement we start with brian newman
who's the band leader and trumpeter for
lady gaga's cheek to cheek album
he's here performing jingle bells we'll
then be treated to a performance from
john d domenico
an emmy nominated actor writer and
comedian
who's best known for his impersonation
of donald trump
he'll join us as austin powers with a
special message
in just a couple of minutes but first
here's brian newman
dashing through the snow you know one
horse open sleigh
or the fields we go laughing all the way
those bells on five tail rings
they're making spirits pride what fun it
is to laugh and sing his lanes on new
night
i'll jingle bells jingle bells jingle
all the way
oh what fun it is to ride in a one-horse
open sleigh hand jingle bells jingle
bells jingle all the way
oh what fun did his two ride in a
one-horse open sleigh
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
they're making spirit pride what fun it
is to laugh and sing a slay song tonight
oh jingle bells jingle bells jingle all
the way
oh what pundit has to hide into one
horse open sleigh head
jingle bells jingle bells jingle all the
way
oh what time
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much las vegas we love you
i heart radio we miss you guys
thank you so much for having us babies
we'll see you soon hats and cats
[Music]
fishing groovy right on baby yeah
it's me austin christmas powers and it's
my
favorite time of year baby that's why
i've got all my red
suit hohoho
[Laughter]
they call me the international man of
mystery baby but it's no mystery why i'm
here
it's to wish you a very sunny christmas
that's alex physician told me that eight
news now sunny 106.5
and i heart radio are encouraging
everyone
and i mean everyone to donate to
opportunity village smashing baby
opportunity village yeah
and they made it incredibly simple to
donate go to
ob gift dot com that's o
v g i f t dot com
children organizations have been hit
particularly hard during covert
so they want to let you know no amount
is
too small no amount whatever you can
give will mean the world to the
wonderful people of opportunity
village baby yes opportunity village is
a
not-for-profit organization that serves
adults
in southern nevada with intellectual and
related
disabilities opportunity village is
there
to enhance the lives of those adults and
the lands of the families who love and
care for them
it's so wonderful give what you can this
season and you will feel
groovy baby yes yes yes yes yes
and remember it's obvious.com
yeah baby
maybe thanks for tuning in i'm brayden
mcnabb from the vegas golden knights
merry christmas from my family to yours
if you're able to support
our friends at opportunity village
please visit obgift.com
a very sunny christmas on eight news now
is sponsored by subaru of las vegas
eight news now and sunny 106.5 present
a very sunny christmas a special benefit
for opportunity village
in this unprecedented year without the
magical forest las vegas headliners and
performers are coming together to raise
money for opportunity village and get us
into the holiday spirit
join us friday december 18 to 3 p.m for
a very sunny christmas
on 8 news now a very sunny christmas
on 8 news now is sponsored by subaru
of las vegas
[Music]
welcome back to a very sunny christmas
the man commanding this next act
is the only person in the world to win
america's got talent
two times his show limitless normally at
the mirage
redefines close-up magic here to wow us
is shin lim hello everybody this is shin
lin and i have just
the magic trick for you guys this
holiday season
check it out it's with a deck of cards
and we'll give it a mix
of course don't think of this so much as
a card trick think of this as more
of a story of uh of life
and you see in life we obviously have
ups and downs
but i think most recently we can all
agree it's been extremely
crazy especially with covid
19. it's affected all of us obviously we
can't get together
physically however i think we all know
in order to go through these hardships
uh we need to
need to work really hard we also need to
stay strong mentally
and adapt to the changes and the climate
as well as have hope that things will
get better
but most importantly most importantly
it's love
love of friends and family
because individually we're fine but i
think we all know
that together we are
stronger look i know
you and i both know that uh by ourselves
we can of course
ace things but i can promise you that
together
as a community especially this
holiday season
work together as one group we can really
accomplish
anything thank you so much for watching
my name is sherman
hello it's performance dragon i miss
jade simone
here to spread some holiday cheer and
who better to spread some holiday cheer
than little mr pefus
well too bad because he's in hawaii look
at that as soon as the pandemic hit
went on vacation and he's left me here
to pay the bills ever since
fine we can make up for it almost as
good as mr piffles
direct from the mirage he's currently
doing a show with shin lim
it's colin clown how you doing colin oh
i'm very well mr fifth the magic dragon
how are you
i'm very good thank you colin i'd like
to offer you one of my prizes from this
delicious catalogue of prizes oh
whoa look at these 25 different items in
a step back
i'm gonna load them on screen for you
colin so you can see them just there
okay you like those bad boys do you like
them bad boys
all right colin here's what you're gonna
do you're gonna close your eyes con okay
you're gonna close your eyes you're
gonna take your finger
you're gonna wear your finger around
you're gonna place it anywhere on your
screen that you like colin
anywhere on your screen once you've done
that you're going to open your eyes and
you're going to tell me
what prize is your finger nearest ah
it's actually on it's on
it is on mr piffles
what yep so mr piffles
he's in he's in hawaii carlyle he's not
with us anymore yeah
oh hang on a minute hang on i think i
might have a picture of him uh
oh there we go tada mr piffles ah
okay no i i get it i get it you've been
working with shim lim too long you used
to much more impressive magic
fine colin fine let's get mr pivots back
from hawaii to las vegas by a pif
airliner
[Applause]
i'd like to say thank you this is for
you i'll be fedexing this to your house
and we'll see you at the mirage see you
soon guys
see you soon and we will see you
everyone at home at the flamingo
me peptomatic dragon mr piffles and jade
[Music]
simone
next performer is a southern soul singer
and las vegas headliner and john he just
released a christmas album on november
1st
and it is flying off the shelves here
with silent night is
michael grimm
[Music]
silence
[Music]
sleep in heavenly
[Music]
peace
[Music]
quakes
[Music]
heaven host
sing hallelujah
christ the savior
is born
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
[Music]
heart
[Music]
listen
[Music]
hey this is jonathan marceau from my
family to yours merry christmas
if you can support our friends at
opportunity village
visit ovgif.com
a very sunny christmas on eight news now
is sponsored by subaru of las vegas
eight news now and sunny 106.5 present
a very sunny christmas a special benefit
for opportunity village
in this unprecedented year without the
magical forest las vegas headliners and
performers are coming together to raise
money for opportunity village and get us
into the holiday spirit
join us friday december 18th at 3 p.m
for a very sunny christmas
on 8 news now a very sunny christmas
on 8 news now is sponsored by subaru of
las vegas
welcome back our next guest is about to
launch a nationwide tour
marie osmond calls him a rising star
with a once in a generation voice
here's las vegas very own daniel emmett
oh holy night
the stars are brightly shined
it is the night of a dear savior's birth
long lay the word
in sin and ever
[Music]
we
[Music]
a new and glorious
[Music]
voices divine
all night
when christ was born
one night
all night one night
[Applause]
ever
[Music]
cry
[Music]
[Music]
when christ was born
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
to close out the show we're bringing in
a performer known as the king of las
vegas
before we do we like to thank all of our
performers
who gave their time to help out
opportunity village it's been a real
pleasure to see these acts perform
especially in light
of what's happened this year so here
with us now closing out our show and
performing for you to watch from the
comfort of your own home
is mr wayne newton
[Music]
oh dancer hold on prancer
[Music]
rudolph behave
twas the night before christmas i
arrived all alone
to a one-bedroom house made of plaster
and stone
i had come down the chimney with
presents to give
and to see just who it was in this house
did live
i looked all about in a strange sight i
did see
no tinsel no presence not even a tree
no stockings by the mantle just boots
shined on a stand
on the wall on pictures of far distant
lands
with metals and badges awards of all
kinds
a somber thought came to mind
this house was different with no lights
it was jury i had found the home of a
soldier
once i could see clearly
the soldier lay sleeping silent
alone curled up on the floor of this
one-bedroom home his face was so gentle
no food could i see this was not how
i had envisioned an american soldier to
be
[Music]
was this the hero of whom i had read
curled up on a poncho the floor for a
bed
soon round the world the children would
play and grown-ups would celebrate a
bright christmas day
i realized the families that i saw this
night
owed their lives to these soldiers who
were so willing to fight
we all enjoy freedom each month of the
year
because of the soldiers like the one
line here
and i couldn't help but wonder how many
lay along
on a cold christmas eve in the land
so far far from home
the very thought brought a tear to my
eye and i dropped to my knees
and i started to cry
the soldier awakened and i heard a clear
voice say santa don't cry
this life is my choice i fight for
freedom and i don't ask for more
[Music]
my life is my god my country
my core
[Music]
the soldier rolled over and drifted to
sleep and
i couldn't control it i continued to
weep
[Applause]
[Music]
i kept watch for hours so silent and
still
and we both shivered from the cold
night's chill
[Music]
i didn't want to leave on that cold dark
night
this guardian of honor so willing to
fight
[Music]
then the soldier rolled over once more
and with his heart so pure he whispered
carry on santa it's christmas
all is secure
[Music]
[Applause]
without looking at my watch
i knew he was right
[Music]
merry christmas my friend
and to all
[Music]
[Music]
indeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you